le 169 rue mais nous y sommes
présentement et vous nous excuserez si
madame et moi vu les rats nous avons
pris certaines précautions
madame abadie je crois vous êtes ici
depuis longtemps depuis 20 ans oui et
qu'est ce que vous faites exactement aux
169 rue oui mais vous êtes la fleuriste
et vous vous occupez de l'ap la terre et
il ya longtemps que cette invasion de
rats qui est produite
oui et selon vous ça tient parfois
matière et le canal acoustique et pas
très loin d'ailleurs oui un vétérinaire
ça serait plutôt fait pour tuer les rats
il ya les magasins généraux si je crois
dans le 19ème parité oui et puis des tas
de déchets du sinn de magasins de
ceux-là j'aimerais savoir madame vous en
avez vu des rentes et votre mari m'a dit
tout à l'heure ça vous empêcher de
dormir comprendre ou d'être parmi vous
avez un chien à cause d'erreurs il n'est
pas très gros ce schéma-là mail les rats
que vous avez vu madame sont gros comme
quoi comme ça notamment que rien fait
moi voir à peu près là la longueur
s'entretient tombes des rats comme ça
ben deja comme ça ça devrait manger
votre chien il en a peur aussi pour plus
tard quand il va grandir il tuera les
rats de la rue de crimée sud par la
guerre aura de la rue depuis la guerre
de dilemme comment s'appelle-t-il lpl
bon eh bien madame je vous souhaite
bonne chance à vous et à popol et on
dévore
[Musique]